welcome back to new rock stars what if
episode 4 gave us our most depressing
ending to one of these stories yet like
i i wanted to cry i really did but is
doctor strange more powerful when he's
evil and did we really need to see the
complete annihilation of an entire
universe like will somebody please just
give christine some damn creme brulee
can just call the kid from high school
musical one and two and three uh that
love the creme brulee and just give it
to christine because that's all she
wanted not creme brule death anyway this
is rogue theory the show that will
re-pitch the wildest theories for the
nerdy titles that you love my name is mt
and going rogue with me today is the
always awesome talented and lovely
jessica coleman's what's going on josh
hey you know give me justice or give me
creme brule death you know
[Laughter]
and also returning to rogue theory is
comedian and host of the blurbs in the
hood show my man jay washington what's
poppin jay all i know is i want to see
the ancient one keep having that black
mother attitude like what are you doing
what did you do
black mother black mother attitude with
the worst animation
oh my god
her mouth was just like mad man
it was just very weird but that's till
the swings real mouth so exactly exactly
exactly
they were two cannons two cannons
oh my gosh and finally our own little
library of cagliostro bookworm mr tommy
beck told what's going on man
i just want to say creme bruh
creme brulee hey to all my friends out
there
and uh also i'm currently renting this
space for advertising anyone would like
to put uh i almost said if anyone would
like to put something on these cheeks
and then i got terrified about what the
comments i'll put something on them
well this is a whole new rogue theory
anyway uh so yes now let's talk about
some what if guys because now that the
same tentacle monster has returned in
episode four that you know captain
carter fought episode one what the hell
are these things and does a trailer
image showing captain carter and strange
supreme meeting imply a finale episode
in which these two team up to bring this
monster down i think the tentacle
monster is just the
the what if punching bag i think it's
genuinely gonna be you know it's gonna
be like in every other episodes just
getting its ass kicked and being ripped
apart but i do think i would love a
finale where everyone somehow teams up
but i think them using the tesseract to
go back through they can open up another
interdimensional like whatever whole and
that's where peggy carter jumps through
and sees this evil doctor strange but i
also think that because mcu loves doing
this in trailers it could just be a
memory like it could just be like a
figment of the imagination or something
like even like using telepath like being
telepathic the evil doctor strange could
reach peggy carter and be talking to
them but in that trailer he says who are
you so maybe she is the one entering his
dimension and entering his mind but i
don't i know how you're like this is
rogue theory jessica you have to come
with like what it's going to be i don't
know but i think those are like notes
that we should shut up jay i think those
are notes
that you should hold on to
because it's just it's so important to
understand that like he
i i don't think it's real i don't think
it's a real moment okay but let me ask
you jessica what the hell do you think
the tentacle monster is though i just
think it's a mystic bean yeah when he
was fighting all of the mystic beans in
the earlier episode i think it's just
like this is the strongest one i don't
think it's of any importance but i could
be completely wrong this is rogue theory
so i'd like to hear but i do think it's
just gonna be the punching bag
throughout the episodes i don't think
it's gonna be
um for continuity say gonna be used in
like the mcu like movies all right yo
jay what do you think the the technical
monster is i think it's uh i think no i
i think it's a background anime actor
that's making 120 per 8 hours and it
just wants to be singing in the singers
we're in the middle of a reception
people and soccer has to work i just
think it's likely it's very like
it's the extra from the chuck e cheese
band that couldn't get put on and he
just tried to keep coming back
i think it might be the mcu's cthulhu it
might be
it might be the mcu
okay just their version of it but again
that's why we only see the tentacles we
don't really see the base of it you know
what i'm saying so i think they're
saving the base
for this big team but again like jessica
said the mcu is known for giving you
images trailers scenes that aren't in
the final product that you are expecting
to see so they could be throwing
something at us like what if doctor
strange and peggy carter team up and
then you'd be like oh that's it that's
the episodes and it never happened so it
couldn't be that i'm saying but again i
think it's an actor that went to central
casting and they told it to appear at
the anime studio
and they were like you're gonna get 120
off for these eight hours you're gonna
sit in the worst conditions and you can
hear it on the screen it got bumped up
you know what i'm saying like you got a
period two feet he was like oh i made it
he threw he threw a watch party for
himself twice was like you can see
jay me is pitching cats don't dance and
i just want that to be very clear right
now this is just cats don't dance all
over again
wow that's plagiarism
that's a crime
that's a crime but no okay so jay so in
this you know the potential captain
carter doctor strange team up how do you
think that'll come about well steven
strange as we're talking about is hella
depressed after doing the worst spells
ever
and just ending everything and i think
we'll start seeing because again this is
the entire phase of the mcu we're in is
mystic cosmic magic so different portals
can be opened up and i think owatu
finally will get involved
because it set up him saying i can't get
involved because if i get involved more
things happen so he will finally get
involved and remember they're saying
what if it's canon
so
we're going into spider-man no way home
doctor strange into the multiverse of
madness so i think watson might get
involved and this sets into pulling in
the heroes because that whole beginning
is one event can make new heroes so now
we get t'challa's star-lord now we get
peggy captain carter all these different
people fighting this giant monster
that's a background extra that's finally
gonna get bumped up to feature pay then
and you know what i'm saying
away from the sad card because you want
everybody
yes god bless god bless
oh my god jay we love you we love you so
much all right tommy what you got for us
well that i you know mine is very very
similar to what jay just said i think
that we are all leading up to the last
episode of what if being what if the
watcher interfered because we are just
being inundated with you know
lots of uh him reminding us that he just
watches and does not mess anything up
because the results will be catastrophic
but what if the results are already
catastrophic if you look at the episodes
that we've had of this show the theme is
kind of like twilight zoney where like
it always ends kind of with a mysterious
or negative thing like we've got evil
doctor strange trapped in a faberge egg
right now where universe has been
destroyed and he's just sitting there
like what chaos what chaos have i
wrought what have i done oh no and i
think what it's going to be is finally
it's going to get so out of whack and
things are going to be so out of control
that that the watcher will have no
choice but to come in and kind of like
take a nice dyson vacuum to the
multiverse and just clean everything up
a little bit
have they not said it's renewed for a
second season it is renewed for a second
i think it is don't you think it'd be a
little too quick for the watcher to jump
into [ __ ] like that
i mean
an infinite number of uh of what if
universes open up from his involvement
we learned the consequences of him
fixing things are not as always as they
seem i mean it would be very you know
very appropriate for the tone of the
series if he goes and interferes it puts
captain carter and doctor strange
together to fight this cosmic being and
then just as all seems to have been
reset and and fixed
uh there's a evil element cracking up
through the surface yeah you know some
something something has been unleashed
something has been awoken from all of
this interfering
jay's hands are august
okay i think it might be cthulhu the
tentacle monster or it could be the
mcu's version of harvey weinstein there
you go i'm done i'm out oh oh my god oh
my god creepy fingers yeah aka creepy
fingers but no i really like what was
brought up before about you know uh the
watcher you know dying like in being
able to die because if this is a
multiversal threat if this is like an
interdimensional tentacle threat you
have to imagine that the watcher is not
safe as well probably um if if this ends
up being a major threat
he talls strange yeah because strange
even says aren't you a god you can fix
this and he literally said the watcher
says i'm not a god
so if i'm not a god i can die exactly
what if the watcher just doesn't
recognize himself as a god but he
recognizes himself as something else but
how we see him is as a god because i
mean the the the list to be a god is
very uh what we see is pretty like heavy
but to him he's like it's nothing and
it's like but you are a god to us you
are what you can do you are doing this
you are all knowing you see everything
and you don't meddle in the behavior of
what we're doing you are a god you're
bigger than a god than the celestials
because they interference like you so
he's trans beauty is what you're saying
he's transgender
sure yeah yeah yeah i'll say that um
does that give me a point empty because
i'll say
does that mean honestly honestly
literally all of this discussion has
been like phenomenal so everyone here
gets two points
two points each oh i mean sorry this is
i'm doing the show so two thousand
points each wow because that's how we do
this is how you lose track of points and
this is how you lose track of points
when you give us this i love thousands
it's true i will lose track of all of
these points this feels great but no
like no this is all some great stuff but
like before we move on to the next topic
which is which is about the watcher if
you guys just like take a wild stab
because i know that jay said like this
is their version of cthulhu but so for
um for tommy and jess who do you guys
think this technical monster is are you
going to be as ridiculous as you want
like it doesn't have to be i like that
well other than what i said before i
like the idea of the tentacle monster
being the evil doctor strange because
when he did absorb him he was able to
like to he had the appearance of all the
mystic beings that he absorbed so what
if when he's fighting he's sticking like
his hands outside of what we saw peggy
carter fighting and when they got in
there this could be a scene from that
situation of them maybe talking or maybe
they don't get along together well
through that talk and he's like i'm
gonna get out whether or not you like it
or not and they start fighting she cuts
off his fingers and that's what we see
with nick fury and hawkeye um in the
first episode of what if so i like the
idea of it being doctor dr squidward i
dig it
right
it's strange
so what you're saying jess is and here's
my go off
tommy my bad i love you bro here's mine
so what you're saying is doctor strange
is a great date at the movie theater
with tentacle fingers all right i'm done
there we go oh
my god
let's continue on with the show um let's
talk about our merch partners an epic
hero you have some really cool limited
edition t-shirts inspired by spider-man
no way home what if loki and all the
other properties we talk about here on
rogue theory you know all the time and
they've also got great new rock stars
hoodies suicide squad laptop sleeves
your laptops get cold and anything else
you might need for some nerdy
back-to-school shopping the school's
coming back i'm sorry children it's
inevitable um so show your support for
new rockstars and get yourself some
great gear at newrockstarsmerch.com and
who knows maybe you find a partner that
i mean your future partner that's
wearing new rockstars merch and then
that's how you guys get together and
then you guys have babies
[Laughter]
yes name your first two children after
me and jess jess first and then mt
because empty's more weird it's a
weirder name um but anyway before we
continue we want to thank our friends at
blue chew for sponsoring this episode of
rogue theory our friends at blue chu
have a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost yeah you
know jay's got some jay i swear to god
oh my god he's waiting he's prepared
luchu is an online prescription service
so no doctor's office or pharmacy trips
necessary and it ships straight to your
door in a discreet package so no one's
going to know what you've got in there
what you need for your bedtime
activities you sign up at bluetooth.com
and consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you receive your prescription
within days and their licensed medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredient and strength and if you
hate swallowing pills good news blue
chew is chewable just like it says in
the name so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time for to
perform and you know during those sexy
times visit blueshoe.com for more
details and important safety information
and we got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free and use our
promo code rogue at checkout just pay
five dollars at shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code rogue to receive
your first month for free and thanks to
bluechu for sponsoring this video again
so if you're carrying a credit card
balance month after month it can feel
like you're in a never-ending cycle of
debt like when lady siff kept kneeling
thor in the groin in a time loop which
is not fun for your groin uh you need
that if you need to if you want to make
children in the future and upstart can
help you make that final payment so that
you can get ahead and upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online so
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment an upstart
knows you're more than just your credit
score and it's expanding access to
affordable credit and unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and current employment to find you a
smarter rate for your loan so with a
five-minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front for loans between
1000 to 50 000 and you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan they are not kidding
i literally did this and it was it's
very fast so find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
rogue that's upstart.com rogue and do
not forget to use our url to let them
know that we sent you and loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application so
please go to upstart.com
rogue all right gang let's talk about
our second topic of the day because is
anyone else in the mcu powerful enough
to communicate with the watcher because
in that moment in episode of four of
what if i was like oh my god he heard
the watcher talking to us and then he's
now directly talking to the watcher at
the end it blew my mind so like is there
anyone else in the mcu powerful enough
to actually communicate with the watcher
like who else do you think can do this
oh i know every black woman in the mcu
every black woman can hear everything no
matter where it is i grew up with a
black mama let me tell you something so
that means angela bassett's ramonda can
definitely hear everything the watcher
got to say because the black mama can't
hear any let me tell you we all weak
look the two of us should know just the
three of us jessica you me and him teach
you know a black mama can't hear
anything you say from a mile away when
you mumbling under your breath so that
means
that she could hear that she could hear
the watcher she can hear that you can
hear the watch absolutely i remember
that i got vibranium
it absorbs the sound i remember that day
my mom threw a remote at the watcher's
back of his head when he said something
bad about him my mom did that to me
if my mom is watching this linda
clements you know exactly what
that comcast remote
the speed
[Laughter]
but to be fair i said something not
miles i said something i'm i like i i
probably said something but also going
back to what you said originally sorry
uh yeah wanda is wanda is wanda can
because i'm only saying that because in
a one division agatha was like you're
stronger than the sorcerer supreme and i
think there's something telling in this
episode of when doctor strange was able
to kind of hear him
but not able to actually see or hear him
he sensed him a little bit but not until
he became not until you became the
sorcerer supreme knight or well not
until he became evil doctor strange so
because that's when he absorbed all the
powers so i think it was really telling
for to be like oh he wasn't there yet
fully but when he absorbed the other
doctor strange he was able then to see
the sort or to see the watcher so i
think wanda and him definitely can see
it in the mcu in the mcu those two
absolutely can see the watch i would say
anyone in possession of all of the
infinity stones would be able to
so so let's see we have three people
that have ever had all the infinity
stones right hulk tony stark and thanos
right so
i would say if they had
at the time of possessing all of the
stones decided to use that i believe
they could reach out to the watcher and
communicate back and forth with all of
the abilities to
bend space time and and everything yeah
so would that be anybody at the tva
would that be anybody at the tva no no
because of the drawer the drawer
junk paperweights
paperweight infinity stones like you
know saying again in the tva they don't
work but these beings now can basically
wield them in the tva go outside and who
we don't know what exactly may happen
like we just look at the all-powerful as
he who remains in loki and yeah of
course wanda but we don't realize
whatever happened to dude uh george
whatever his name was the dude at the
desk like could he be somebody we don't
know you know oh yeah okay you know we
always have eugene
yeah people jean baby cordero
who we think are throwaway characters
but they may be somebody in the grand
scheme of things okay y'all tell me to
go rogue that's what i do okay you know
okay that's too wrong i know that that
that's a very that wasn't right because
like the tva has had dealings with the
watcher in the comics so like
it's it's not very rogue it's very
inline it makes a lot of sense the mcu
i i'm comics aside in the mcu are we
seeing are we saying that uh the watcher
i always took it as the watcher lives
outside of like time outside of that own
existence of time because he's able to
see every universe right so
i don't think the stones could reach him
because it's on a different existence
like how dorm it was
yeah like
was his own timer you had to like he had
to leave his time in order to fight
dormant i think that with the watcher he
lives in his own existence and that's
why those that can reach that plane can
enter or talk to the watcher or see at
least what about
outside of the mcu what about the fox
marvel universe what about charles
xavier
pushed into cerebro no that's actually
good i like this amplified xavier
he's like who's that who's that who's
that
what's in my box who's thinking about
what i'm thinking
who told me to get a gillette razor who
said gillette razors it's your bald
brother
no no i think that'd be really fun like
okay no let's let's let's go on with
this who do you think in the x-men
universe in the fox universe could
communicate with the world jane grey
jean two people
yeah jean grey and she's great okay
jean grey jean grey
because she spits hot fire
because she spits her fire
like i think every all of us went to
that was so quick all of us went to like
jade or jessica chastain
because she just wants to be there or
maybe where maybe where maybe we're
looking at the wrong fox of marvel
movies perhaps dr doom as god oh doctor
doom absolutely
absolutely only if it's julian
only if it's julian mcmahon's doctor
doom though yes yes yes exactly i don't
know
the the name of the other actor no one
does i didn't watch that no one does
tony campbell
uh tommy just said it i'm so sorry
thank you wow you're you're a good man
listen um okay my white mother maybe
couldn't hear everything
special boy that could whisper whatever
i wanted under my
under my breath oh my god you should
never let me forget the stars of the
fantastic four reboot and i thank you
for that this is what boss feels like
every time
i think so i think so
so ridiculous i love it
um okay i'm going to give
jess and tommy one point each but i'm
going to give jay two points
because i think the tba like especially
casey i think there's an opportunity for
casey to come back and play a bigger
role here um and like because like in
people in the tva can't talk to the
watchers so i think i really like that
tva angle so yeah
is it because he's wearing a wu tang
shirt
for the children yes that's exactly it
uh it's the for the children it's for
the children or the children
uh w is the letter of the day uh
[Laughter]
but anyway um let us continue on to one
of my favorite segments of all the
segments that we do even though i love
all the segments the rogue question now
dc has just announced that its fandom
events will occur on october 16th and
will reveal a host of trailers footage
and other announcements for upcoming dc
projects and one of these is an animated
film dc league of super pets so please
my friends
pitch me your weirdest concept for a dc
heroes or villains matching pet
companion oh my god oh my god
this is a good one okay
i i got i've got one if i could go first
go for it so my pitch
is uh dc super pets
colon
super villains colon 101 salvation
it is
the super pets of the dc universe are
getting picked off by a serial killer
and it's none other than
that it's none other than the then the
hairless
cat owned by dr doolmacher aka the doll
maker who is
the cat who has now been infused with
the intelligence of the doll maker is
going around killing krypto the super
dog all of the other ones all of the
other superpowers of which i don't know
and could name skinning them making them
into clothing making them into coats and
there can only be one
one pet that can save them all and that
is of course uh
i i'm gonna assume the wonder woman has
like uh like a gecko or something like
that and it's the geico gecko in a
tie-in
dignified promotional tie-in the geico
gecko goes one-on-one yes with the doll
maker's cat uh the doll maker's [ __ ] if
you will uh and uh can't forget about
the dollar got my attention now
so that yeah that is my uh half-baked
pitch for
for the dc universe a hundred dollars i
got one i got one um sounds very
derivative i'm scared now that's really
great
okay go for it i don't have a title but
i like the idea of all of the
superheroes in the dc universe or
kind of anti-heroes that are all animals
that have their own pets but their pets
are just acting like humans hear me out
so we have a real we have batman right
what if we get man bat but it's not the
man bat from the dc universe it's
not the man from the dc universe it's a
bat that acts like a human and then we
get catwoman but we get woman cat and
it's a cat that's naked and acts like a
human
hear me out i know it sounds pretty
strange but then we get like scarecrow
right but it's just a dead man
a dead corpse that like jumps up and
it's like oh i'm alive so i think if we
got like the
you know that crazy and then we got the
guy that did joker to direct it and
write it and it'll be grungy
both jessica and my movie pictures are
directed are produced by blumhouse as
well copenhagen
child animation movies i mean naturally
monkey paw productions tried to get on
it and then they were like actually this
sounds too stupid
so
monkey pro productions monkey paw
productions and jordan peel actually
produce mine it's the dc super pets stop
the cairns everywhere this is what
happens the world is being overrun by a
legion of karen's right like the the
caring chick in central park and just
like the real world like the real world
right so they're karen's everywhere
they've taken over they beat up on lex
luthor because they got him cancelled
they beat up on the joker they wiped his
face paint off and called his mama like
these cairns are everywhere right and so
all of a sudden there's a leader of all
the cairns and these pets have to get
together and figure out what karen is
causing all this and we found out that
the ultimate karen in the dc universe is
lois lane like she sits atop the daily
planet yeah and she just makes superman
her [ __ ] like she has him on a leash
and clark is just
so
all of a sudden but then black people
are there and they just watching
everything they're just not doing
nothing they like these white people in
their pets and then all of a sudden it
just ends produced by jordan that's it
oh my goodness i like that you out at
lois lane for the for the karen that she
is
i would like to speak to the manager
[Laughter]
the manager of the daily planet got me
this
good
job
my father
do you know who my father is
i love how jay said that they called the
joker's mama even though no one knows
who the joker's mama is the karen's just
they find out it's like they correctly
guessed the joker's mama it's like
listen batman been canceled like can you
understand bruce wayne has been
cancelled like it's a bunch of cameras
that sit at the bat cave and you like
how
y'all by the bat cave
there is a man in black
but i'm going to give three points to
miss jessica clements for that really
interesting
idea for the for the like man bats and
the pets i think it's really fun like
have a a woman i can't act like a woman
why not it's just really fun she's just
walking on her two paws
she's very i'm just like you i'm just
like you
she's typing on the computer really
quick with our paws
it's a good idea x the scarecrow idea
but the rest is really good
yes 3 000 points to jess which i believe
makes jess our winner for today's rogue
theory hooray claps for jess
i will take one dr strange tentacle
finger please ma'am
sorry children
rated x
we'll see you on the rule 34 forums
thank you all for joining us today i
want to thank our guest jess clemens jay
washington then tommy beck told please
follow them on twitter wherever they are
and please support everything that
they're doing because they're all doing
amazingly creative stuff so please head
to the twitters and then find their
links everywhere but of course support
our channel by checking out all of our
new limited edition no way home merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
at mastertainment but most importantly
all the new rockstars everywhere we are
especially on twitter.com because tyler
he's killing it but also if you do it on
youtube hit that notification bell so
you get notifications whenever i upload
a video thank you guys for watching we
love you guys so much goodbye
[Music]
you